make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and we are picking back up with
the conclusion of the avengers enter the
phoenix storyline right like this great
big huge tournament that's going on on
earth with regards to
answering the question of who gets to
wield the phoenix force in the last
video we basically ended with neymar the
submariner empowered by the phoenix
facing off against echo who was
empowered by the phoenix and again echo
is basically just the girl version of
taskmaster but she has the ability to
duplicate the the fighting style of
anybody she sees and all she has to do
is just see them fight in order to be
able to duplicate it but the whole idea
behind this is we get this this
interesting little bit of a discussion
with neymar the submariner where he kind
of talked about when he was a little kid
and a bull shark that was a lot bigger
than him had basically gone to bite him
and he drug it to the surface and then
he threw it on the surface
and then his mom chastised him right she
yelled at him at the idea that he was
acting very much like a surface dweller
right that just you know that we on the
surface just more or less kill
indiscriminately and there's no real
reason why i mean you know we do it to
like
you know to to feed ourselves but we
also do it for you know
petty vendettas and things like that and
so the idea was that she kind of posed a
question to him like are you going to be
the kind of person
who kills indiscriminately like people
on the surface or are you going to be
like a king down in atlantis and the
response of neymar was pretty
interesting there where he basically
said that the the philosophy he held
is that he would kill anything that
tried to attack him so that everything
in the ocean would learn
not to attack him and his mother found
happiness in that right she was
satisfied with that answer and he
basically carries this over right in the
sense that with name with a submariner
it's not enough to be a king of atlantis
right that's one of the things to
understand it's not enough that he's a
king of atlantis he wants the surface
world to know not to mess with him
either but neymar is one of these guys
where he always kind of has a chip on
his shoulder if i'm being honest right
like the world's got it out for him he's
always got to prove to the world that
he's a top dog right just kind of walk
around with a chip you know
that kind of a thing like he's always
got something to prove but the important
thing here is
even with the abilities that echo has
the reality is her weakness comes in the
fact that she's never faced someone like
neymar the submariner
underwater right it's just a situation
she's never been exposed to before now
having said that following this fight
she would become capable in doing the
problem is that namorson you know
basically
you know sends a bunch of sharks on her
and then attacks her sends her down
below into the mariana trench and then
more or less leaves her for dead
right and that's just kind of it so he
ultimately ends up becoming quote
unquote the winner of this fight and so
from there you switch over to what's
probably one of the more interesting
fights here which is shang chi and
captain america now here's the thing to
understand about this right when it
comes to shang chi he's a master of kung
fu right he's a master of really kung fu
and wushu if we're being honest with
ourselves but the thing about captain
america is he is
versatile in a multitude of different
fighting styles and is a master in some
of them right so it's one of these
things right who wins this fight a jack
of all trades or a master of one thing
and so it's it's it's kind of cool there
because one of the things that's kind of
hit out here by jason aaron is that
chiang chi
is in some ways not as prodigious of a
fighter as captain america is and i
would kind of argue that point
right i would argue that shang chi is a
much better fighter than captain america
but captain america also knows multiple
fighting styles and that's one of the
interesting things there because when
you look at shang chi and the idea that
he taught peter parker the way of the
spider and taught him his own fighting
style
that it wasn't rooted in like taekwondo
or judo
or brazilian jiu jitsu right or kenpo or
anything like that it was just
rooted in in what is effectively kung fu
and wushu and so
it's interesting to see this because
ultimately you have this kind of a a
little
smidge of a discussion here where
captain america kind of talks about the
idea that all of them have spent so long
fighting
over who it is that should not be the
host of the phoenix
force that none of them have asked the
question who should it be and in captain
america's eyes
it should be shang chi and the reason
for this is because shang chi
is is probably one of the most gifted
fighters on the face of the planet but
what makes him
so capable and what makes shang chi such
a great person to have on your team
despite the fact that ali can really do
his hand to hand fighting is he's so
good at
centering himself he's so good at
putting emotion at bay
and fighting like just cleanly and
logically right just focusing on the
situation at hand
and moving forward in that capacity and
that's why captain america says like i
want to train you right i want to help
you hone your fighting style and your
skills i want you to become the best
host for the phoenix now it's not as
though captain america is like you know
coming out with me and i'll teach you
like the wakandan fighting style and
that kind of stuff
it's more or less kind of helping change
but again i would argue that like there
really isn't much for captain america to
offer here when it comes to shang chi
right he's just he's not like he's this
brash and reckless kid who's just
fighting more with heart than mine he's
he's
clear-headed right he's probably the
best fighter on the face of the planet i
would say he is
i think he really is the best fighter on
on the face of the earth maybe outside
of taskmaster right taskmaster
could probably get the upper hand on
shang chi outside of taskmaster
i think that like he's the best fighter
on earth but again it's one of these
these interesting things where
ultimately shang cheese just like
and really even captain america kind of
agrees one of us has to win
and so ultimately shang chi has like
this amazing moment right where he
breaks out his weapon and then you get
just this thing where he comes lunging
at captain america
and it's like this typhoon of fire just
following behind him and then captain
america's whisked away right and that's
basically it and the whole reason behind
that is because
captain america's stance was to kind of
position shang chi
to make him the best host for the
phoenix but that's not the way it's
supposed to be right it's just supposed
to be a knock down drag out fight
between these various heroes to
determine which one of them should be
the should be the next host right so
you can't have people working together
you can't have them like conspiring
and looking to essentially cook the
books and stack the deck in favor of one
particular person like you can't do that
right instead it's just gotta be them
just
knock down drag out bare knuckle
fighting and whoever wins
wins and that's why i say like captain
america is a great fighter don't get me
wrong i'm not like
knocking captain america he's a great
fighter the guy overpowered spider-man
even though spider-man was really didn't
have an actual fighting style
but but at the end of the day like i
would give it to shang chi man let me
know what you guys think i'm curious
what do you got who do you guys think is
a better fighter in marvel comics do you
think it's captain america or do you
think it's shang chi because i really
feel like it's shang chi
here but at the end of the day the
avengers are kind of forming their own
plan their own sort of backup plan
in the sense that as far as they're
concerned the phoenix force can't really
be trusted
and this is one of the things that i'm
not a big fan of in terms of how
marvel's handled the phoenix force
recently right the phoenix force when it
was introduced by chris claremont marvel
comics was more of a philosophical
concept than it was
just like a thing that existed out there
and did some stuff right that the
phoenix force was designed to kind of
represent like this primordial
life-giving force but sort of represent
this idea that even the most pure of
people
can become twisted in evil and become
bad guys right jean grey was by all
standards of measurement pure of heart
and the phoenix force was this concept
that didn't really understand or want to
know good and evil right it was just
this
primordial force but when you look at
chris claremont's x-men run it's kind of
kind of this idea that like the human
race is an infection right it's almost
kind of like a disease or an illness
and everything we touch we screw up and
so when you look at the phoenix for
example when it took control of jean
grey that all the the emotions that gene
you know more or less experienced at
least at the time the story was written
uh corrupted the phoenix force now later
on marvel changed it and basically had
it revealed the fact that the phoenix
just
impersonated jean grey and was not
actually jean grey but the way that
chris claremont originally wrote the
phoenix and dark phoenix stories it was
jean grey right it was literally jean
grey herself so again it's one of those
those interesting things that in a lot
of ways if you look at the phoenix in
the dark phoenix saga it's a cynical
critique on humanity right that we are
really just more of a problem than
anything else and so one of the things
that you get here this is kind of an
interesting situation is you you have a
couple of fights to take place and none
of them are
of any major significance you do get to
see she-hulk as
uh as as the phoenix which is okay i
mean it's interesting you know i mean
you know
it's cool it's it's it's whatever but
you then you end up transitioning to the
ukraine right and you've got chernobyl
the exclusion zone right which most of
you guys know from the chernobyl
meltdown that the radiation there's
insane
and unless you have some kind of a
protective suit you cannot go there
right or you'll grow like
you know two extra eyes and like 15 legs
right it just
it'll kill you right the radiation will
kill you but that's where the vampires
largely dwell in the marvel mythos and
so when you have black panther who's
teleported there black panther basically
comes into contact with wolverine right
wolverine who's imbued with the power of
the phoenix now
the other cool thing that happens here
is that thor begins to kind of launch
this assault that's really designed to
distract the phoenix
alongside carol danvers and iron man and
and ghost rider but the funny thing here
is that the phoenix persona basically
manifests itself to thor
and says no like stop right like like i
need to talk to you thor because there
is a secret that your father never
revealed to you and so from there
what you get kind of focusing on this
wolverine versus a black panther fight
this is an amazing fight here and the
reason why is because it's kind of this
answer to the question like which one's
better
vibranium or adamantium now in reality
those of us who read comics know
adamantium's better the only thing that
can really
take out adamantium is antibiotic or not
really anti-vibranium
uh anti-metal from the arctic right
there's a few different forms of
vibranium that exist in the marvel
universe and depending on where they
landed it changed the principles of that
metal so
what condom vibranium is the vibranium
you most commonly think of right the
great mound in wakanda by which the
nation was built and that's the metal
that like absorbs sound and all that
kind of good stuff
but arctic vibranium basically cuts
through metal like it's anti-metal and
so effectively it doesn't really
cut through it so much as break it down
on the molecular level
as it comes into contact with it now as
far as i'm aware we've never really seen
an instance where you had somebody
possessing like an anti an arctic
vibranium sword
fighting wolverine and then basically
like cutting his claws off i'm not aware
that's ever
actually happened in marvel comics uh so
i'd be curious to see if it did right to
see if that's
actually the case by all standards of
measurement given the principles of
arctic vibranium it should right it
should you know as an anti-metal it
should be able to cut through
wolverine's adamantium but it's one of
these weird things where i'm almost kind
of like nothing can destroy adamantium
nothing can harm adamantium you know so
it's model kind of goes back and forth
right but the long and short here
is that wolverine effectively starts to
get the upper hand on black panther now
one of the things to get here and this
is what makes this fight so cool kind of
like you know wolverine versus black
panther what makes this so cool
is not just the fighting styles that
black panther is trained in a litany of
fighting styles and even
really his core main style of fighting
is rooted in kind of a combination of a
bunch of different styles that he's all
kind of merged together into an
amalgamation
which can kind of be considered like a
wakandan martial art even though that is
its own style of martial art it's what
the dora melasha use but like black
panther has his own unique style
but wolverine has been around for a few
hundred years and he's trained in pretty
much
every martial art that exists right so
wolverine is a prodigious fighter he is
a highly capable fighter
he's not a master of all of them but
he's certainly more skilled than captain
america is you combine that with his
brute force his tactics and the fact
that his body's laced with adamantium
wolverine is a ridiculously hard enemy
to kill
and that's why things are so nuts is
because between the intelligence right
the the mental capacity of t'challa
combined with his fighting style and his
ability to think in the heat of battle
along with wolverine and his his
experiences in combat
the fight is wild and it's amazing right
it's just it's one of these these super
cool things
now ultimately wolverine gets the upper
hand on t'challa right just by ferocity
alone he gets the upper hand on t'challa
pops two of his claws and then goes to
pop the third and the funny thing about
that is he kind of he he has to challah
like so how's you know so what's it
going to be right are you going to like
take the l are you going to submit are
you going to be willing to lose
or am i going to like pop this third
claw and am i going to kill you right
and that's what the child is like i
would actually block it it's like how in
the world would you do that
only for only for us to find out
t'challa has adamantium teeth
ah alright for those of you guys who are
not new to comics this is what we call a
plot device
right it's called doing it just for the
sake of the story this oftentimes
pisses off comic book fans it pisses
comic book fans off in the extreme
other times we don't really care i don't
care i don't get mad about that kind of
stuff anymore right i've been reading
long enough i've seen that
a million times i've seen stories i see
comic book stories that happen
just for the sake of happening i think
it's super cool that like t'challa's
grills are just like adamantium
that's lit like i mean i don't advise
doing it right like don't don't cover
your teeth and metal
but the whole thing about this is is
ultimately like this allows
black panther to get this momentary
upper hand where he literally kicks
wolverine in the balls and then
basically gets the upper hand on him
right and like the fight like like
literally pummels him to death like uses
his claws and just
tears right through wolverine right and
that's and that's the end of that now
ultimately wolverine's healing factor
would allow him to live
and the way this kind of seems to go as
far as the phoenix is concerned is like
if under any other circumstance it'd be
considered a legitimate death
then like they become the winner and
that's basically it right so again you
know the fights kind of continue on and
various people you know various various
foes facing off against each other but
jumping back to thor jason aaron makes
an odd choice here
and the reality is that anybody who's
been reading his avengers run
kind of knew it was coming up to this
point and honestly i'm not necessarily
against it
essentially the phoenix reveals that
it's thor's actual biological mom odin
and the phoenix essentially touch
naughty bits and that it led to the
birth of thor now this is kind of
intriguing because for a long time
thor's mom was gaia right the sentience
of of mother earth but the truth about
this is it never mattered because marvel
never did anything with it right it was
just like it was
it was a thing that was there right and
like that was it it was just a thing you
knew and so you just kind of knew knew
about thor's mom so the reality of this
is
you know anybody who kind of gets pissed
off about this i think is only really
coming from one of two directions
one it's because of how it was done by
jason aaron how it was revealed or two
because they just don't want things to
change because no one
out there right no one out there reading
comics like those are guys who are new
to comics understand this there's no one
sitting in a comic book store right now
who's just
celebrating the fact and has like all
kinds of memorabilia that that
represents the fact that gaia is the
mother of thor right like
no one's out there like that's one of
the greatest moments in comics right
when we learned gaia was the mother of
thor and it's a hallmark of comic book
mythos right like nobody out there is
saying that so in reality i think it's
kind of cool that like thor's mom is the
phoenix now the question to ask here is
what's marvel gonna do with it that's
the real question to ask
but it does in a lot of ways kind of
answer the question why it is a thor's
so
you know literally far more capable than
any of the other asgardians you could
kind of chalk it up to the fact that
he's the son of odin and just sort of
leave it at that and it would make sense
but the idea of him being the son of the
phoenix uh
really kind of adds a lot of explanation
to why it is that he's so powerful
it certainly does a better job of
explaining why he's more powerful than
being the son of like whoopi goldberg
from captain planet right i mean that
certainly makes a lot more sense right
so
again it's a cool concept here i like it
and i'm kind of digging it now of course
this sends thor on a war path he just
kind of refuses to believe
any of what he's hearing and even jason
aaron kind of plays a little fast and
loose and says like i mean you know is
the phoenix really telling the truth
here i mean thor kind of accuses it and
says like i refuse to believe this and
the response to the phoenix as well
you know whether or not you you refuse
to believe it doesn't matter right like
it's still true so
a lot of it seems to be accurate this is
one of those moments in comics where
we're not
actually gonna know it's true until
jason aaron follows up and confirms that
it's true right like
thor goes to odin and odin's like yeah i
basically banged the phoenix at which
point when i was if i was thor i'd be
like i mean damn all right cool man good
on you
right on me oh like the phoenix is hot
like
i didn't even mean to make that pun i
didn't even mean to make that pun
i didn't even mean to make that joke but
like it's it's it's a cool thing right
it's kind of an interesting thing this
look ultimately
the the real meat and potatoes of the
various battles that go on here all
ultimately boil down to really one of
the final fights which is between
black panther and captain america and
this is an
awesome battle that takes place here now
so one of the reasons why this is so
cool
is because of the fact that when you
look at the comic book history of these
two characters
there's a lot of respect that black
panther has for captain america
and a lot of respect that captain
america has for black panther black
panther's respect for captain america is
not just because of his time on the
avengers and captain america's role as a
superhero and how he operates in the
community
it goes all the way back to the fact
that captain america helped fight
alongside the wakandans against the
german invasion during world war ii
like literally against the germans
that's where captain america got the
idea of a circular shield
and where he got his piece of vibranium
that led to his shield becoming you know
being turned into its current form
captain america has a pretty lengthy
history
in terms of his involvement in wakanda
and fighting on behalf of those
individuals who simply can't stand up
for themselves or who just need help
that combined with his role as a
superhero and the larger superhero
community
leaves a lot of respect there for black
panther while captain america doesn't
always agree with his motivations and
doesn't always agree with uh the things
that he does
he understands why he does what he does
right it's one of the things we've
talked about
black panther would let the world burn
if it meant saving wakanda like he would
literally do that he would sacrifice the
world if it meant saving wakanda
the the fight between the two is really
more of a fight of necessity because
they're kind of being forced to
not necessarily because they want to but
they both have their own individual
goals here right t'challa in possession
of the phoenix force would be able to
protect wakanda from any and
all threats that exist out there captain
america in possession of the phoenix
force while it's not his first choice
and he wouldn't really want to be in
possession of the phoenix because of all
the power that it represents he
it could certainly allow him to like
protect the world from seemingly any
threat that was out there
again he wouldn't really use it for
nefarious purposes he wouldn't be a dick
about it but while all these different
fights are going on
and and the fight between captain
america and black panther is seemingly
dead
even you do get this amazing battle
between uh between
neymar the submariner and she-hulk now
one of the things about she-hulk is it's
not as though she's lost control
that's one of the things that she
clarifies she hasn't lost control she
knows exactly what she's doing
if i'm gonna be honest that's the one
thing that really differentiates
she-hulk from like the incredible hulk
is the fact that like she doesn't lose
her mind she doesn't become like savage
she has before
but it takes a special circumstance it's
not her default stage
right the default stage at least it used
to be until immortal hulk the default
stage of the incredible hulk was like
bruce manner turns to the hulk and the
hulk just rampages right and that's it
right just tears things up and that's
all there is to it with she-hulk
jennifer walters could actually turn
into she-hulk at will she could maintain
her own mind right so it was basically
you know a good portion of the
incredible hulk strength not limitless
like the hulk but a good portion of the
hulk strength and then being able to
change back and forth it will right and
so the fight between her and namor
it's pretty intense and and she-hulk
really starts to get the upper hand
and then of course it gets kind of nuts
because she literally rips the arms off
of neymar the submariner which is kind
of nuts like she literally pins him to
the ground
and then rips his arms off and then he
was just like he's like i'm possessed by
the phoenix force and just like pops his
arms back right like regrows his arms
which is kind of nuts
doesn't really grow he just summons them
back and then like reattaches him to his
body but in the midst of all that
you have iron man you've got carol
danvers you've got the rest of the
avengers who really haven't been
selected for this battle
uh basically the ones who were left out
so i guess they weren't cool enough to
be on the kickball team but these guys
end up having their own plan where
they're effectively going to charge up
the the avengers mountain right like the
celestial this prime celestial they're
charging this guy's power up for the
intention of firing it off at the
phoenix and essentially destroying the
phoenix or the very least getting it to
leave the earth
uh now the reality and this is an
important thing to understand here the
power of a celestial
is dwarfed by the power of the phoenix
right the the phoenix forces power
is way beyond anything that any
celestial would have right so
it's really more of just like a last
ditch effort and iron man even goes as
far as to say this is not
a fight that we can win right but like
at the very least we can just do
something right we can try a thing right
and just hope the thing works that like
the phoenix is like okay you know what
screw this and then leaves but like if
the phoenix decides to destroy this
celestial and then destroy us and the
world
there's nothing we can do to stop it and
so in the middle of one of these great
big huge fights suddenly
a hand emerges from the ocean and then
just absorbs the entirety of the phoenix
force from those
from from like both combatants involved
right and then from there
just starts traveling around it takes
the phoenix force off of jennifer
walters it takes the phoenix force off
of namor the submariner it snatches it
away from like captain america and
and black panther it literally just
yanks it away from every single person
and the phoenix force finally realizes
it's chosen as host right but now that
it has his host
the the kind of emissary or the the uh
manifestation of it as it was talking to
thor
leaves right and kind of leaves him with
a lot of unanswered questions right
which is how we know
that thor is going to follow up with a
lot of this stuff by going and talking
to odin right and so following that the
phoenix essentially coalesces into its
proper host
everything more or less stops they're
like okay like we like everybody stops
right and like they're just watching
this whole thing
whole thing go down only for us to find
out the phoenix has effectively bonded
itself
to echo right bonded itself to maya
lopez why it is that jason aaron has
done this
i have no idea presumably because of the
fact that maya is going to appear in the
mcu and the desire here is to raise the
profile of maya lopez and to get people
to notice her
right and then get people to be curious
about her and in turn like want to know
more about her character right so maybe
it's worth us doing a video on maya
lopez explained
honestly we'll probably wait until like
the the the official launch of her
character in the mcu i might just make
the video ahead of time and let it sit
until then i don't really know but
regardless of the situation maya lopez
is now the new host of the phoenix what
that means i have no earthly clue right
the phoenix usually
bolsters the powers of the people that
it possesses but maya lopez's power is
to duplicate the
the the abilities and really just the
fighting style of anybody she sees
you know when you're when you're a
possession of the phoenix force you're
not really an earthbound character
anymore you're not really going to see
somebody who's a host of the phoenix
fighting taskmaster that's not really
going to happen right you know then yeah
i'm on the phoenix force here comes
hydra well time to fight the red skull
you're never going to see that right
like
that's not going to happen like maya
lopez is effectively a multiversal force
of power now
she has the full totality of the
phoenix's power so well at least
assuming she can access the white hot
room she does
but like she's she's a host of the
phoenix she's a universal and
multiversal power force galactus does
not use kung fu as
awesome as it would be to see right it
would be amazing to see galactus just
roundhouse kick
somebody right like roundhouse kick a
celestial that'd be hilarious
but like you know they don't do that
right it's just energy manipulation that
kind of a thing so it may be one of
these things where she becomes something
akin to protege where she can
essentially duplicate the powers of
other people
whenever she sees them use them right
there's no real definitive answers here
instead it's just kind of like we don't
really know like exactly how this is
going to unfold but the important thing
is everything just kind of goes back to
rights and it all just kind of settles
back down
and that's it right like the the victory
has been determined and that victor is
echo so with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you